[Music]
it is no secret that many distributors
and film studios are struggling with the
consequences of the pandemic and are to
raise the budget due to various
interruptions and cancellations this
also seems to have been the case with
mission impossible 7 as the budget for
the action blockbuster was recently
revealed according to reports the budget
so far is a whopping 290 million us
dollar nearly 110 million us dollar more
than the predecessor mission impossible
fallout what is particularly remarkable
is the fact that this not even include
marketing costs there seems to be quite
a bit of cost involved which of course
they want to recoup with a successful
cinema release next year the reason for
the immensely high cost might surprise
many because while the pandemic is
certainly to blame it is also primarily
self-imposed additional measures they
gain special attention when a leak from
the set show tom cruise yelling at a
co-worker without a mask the
internationality of the set must also
play a major role because different
rules and requirements apply in many
parts of the world and this is now
reflected in the budget in order to be
an acceptable success the movies box
office takings would have to be very
close to the 1 billion mark however it
would then be the first movie in the
series to do so in any case we are
excited and look forward to the release
of mission impossible 7 on july 14 2023
despite all the postponements
since wednesday the last episode of the
first season star wars the book of boba
fett has been released but disney is not
even thinking about stopping with the
release of more star wars series on
tuesday disney announced the official
start date of the obi-wan kenobi series
with a brand new poster revealing a
secret that has been well kept for
months the speculation about the start
of the series has been going on for
quite some time and was intensified by a
leak in the last few days the end of may
is supposed to be the time of release
and after the rather mixed reception of
the boba fett series expectations are
correspondingly high that seems to be
the case for actor and leading man ewan
mcgregor as well as the 50 year old
doctor about his return to the general
in the interview with forbes after more
than 15 years according to the interview
he loved playing the role again moreover
there will also be reunion with darth
vader actor hayden christensen and it
will fill a gap from the movies the
audience should finally learn what he
did between revenge of the sith and a
new hope mcgregor is praising director
deborah chao and says he knows the world
of star wars inside out he also said he
believes fans will be pleased with the
result pretty fancy words from mcgregor
who makes no effort to lower the fans
expectations what exactly the series
will look like and above all what
specific role anakin skywalker aka darth
vader will play you can find out from
may 25th 2022 on disney plus by the way
that could be your first taste at the
super bowl many expect the first trailer
there at least it would fit well in
terms of time
it's not just the world of sports that
looks forward to the upcoming super bowl
because movie and series fans will also
be able to see one or two exclusive
trailers for the first time at this
sporting event in the case of amazon's
the lord of the rings series in contrast
to many other premieres the good news
has already been officially announced by
the streaming giant itself this should
of course place the fans after all so
far only short teaser was seen which did
not contain any footage but only the
unveiling of the official title of the
series in addition the first images have
now been released which show impressions
of the new actors of elrond and
galadriel as well as some new characters
developed for the series furthermore
there are some behind the scenes images
which definitely make you want more feel
free to check out our news from last
week if you want to know more about
potential trailers at the upcoming super
bowl the lord of the rings the rings of
power will be released on september 2nd
2022 exclusively on amazon prime video
with its unique animated movie and crazy
universe shenanigans spider-man into the
spider-verse played its way to the
hearts of fans in 2018. the live-action
spin-off no way home also was a great
success with its equally unique
multiverse style that's why it's not
uncommon for both films to be associated
with a crossover the speculation heats
up into the spider-verse producer chris
miller himself because the 46 year old
recently expressed together with his
colleague fellord in the happy said
confused podcast about the mcu crossover
according to them the multiverse is big
and broad and growing all the time so
why shouldn't we be allowed to talk
about connection miller asks they
neither confirmed nor denied the
spider-man crossover but it's also not
the first time they gained attention by
making statements about it either way
we're looking forward to the upcoming
spider-man across the spider verse which
is scheduled for release on october 7th
2022
since the beginning of the year the
fifth part of the call slasher series
scream has been running in cinemas with
box office takings just under 110
million us dollars so far the remake has
grossed 10 million us dollar more than
the previous movie stream for despite
the pandemic that is obviously reason
enough for those responsible to continue
spyglass and paramount pictures let it
be known that they are infinitely
grateful for the fans for the success
and can hardly wait to see what else
they have in store for the franchise the
creative minds behind the movie with a
simple title scream belong to the
collective radius silence that consists
of director duo matt bernelli open
intelligent producer chad villella and
writers james vanderbilt and guy busick
scream is not their first strike in the
horror genre because they already had
some success with vhs and ready or not
filming of this green sequel is
scheduled to start next summer which is
why release during the coming year seems
realistic meanwhile fans of the series
still have the possibility to see the
current hit at the local movie theater
in many parts of the world
with this year's golden globe ceremony
having recently taken place hollywood's
most important film trophy is soon up
for grabs the world famous oscar
the so-called academy awards which are
taking place for the 94th time this year
are once again putting the spotlight on
many current movies with 12 nominations
the drama film the power of the dog
leads the ranking which should of course
make netflix and lead actor vanity
cumberbatch particularly happy much more
surprising are the nominations for the
japanese movie drive my car which is
nominated not only for best picture and
best international feature film but also
for best adapted screenplay danny
velnev's dune is also placed as high as
expected with 10 nominations in addition
to benedict cumberbatch will smith for
king richard javia boredom for being the
ricardo's denzel washington for the
tragedy of macbeth and andrew garfield
for tick tick boom are nominated for
best lead actor on the female side
jessica chastain for the eyes of tammy
faye olivia coleman for the last
daughter kristen stewart for spencer
nicole kidman for being the recorders
and penelope crews for apparel mothers
are competing for the golden trophy hunt
zimmer is also the running on the
musical side as he was at the golden
globes for a soundtrack to dune chances
for the most important trophy for the
best film are not only to just mention
the power of the dog dune and drive my
car but as a west side story don't look
up licorice pizza belfast coda and king
richard the date of the award ceremony
is march 27 2022 at the dolby theater in
los angeles
not only does the marvel universe seem
to be growing incessantly but sony has
also taken important steps towards its
own universe with venom leatherby
carnage and morbius which will be
released on the 1st of april the ssu the
sony spider-man universe was started by
the two venom movies and now a new
character is to enter the stage it has
been announced that finally a leading
actress has been found for sony's madame
web and it is none other than 50 shades
of grey actress dakota johnson for her
this is a well deserved comeback to the
big screen because after the success of
50 shades of grey she didn't start in
a-list movies in recent years her role
cassandra webb also known as madame webb
has been part of the spider-man universe
for over 40 years and made her first
appearance in the comics as an old lady
with a muscle weakness she compensates
for physical limitations with her
brilliant mind which even gives her
telepathic abilities she can also see
into the future which is definitely one
of the more powerful superpowers now
since 32 year old dakota johnson isn't
known for acting old women we're
assuming the newman and web project to
be an origin story about the
superheroine the people behind the movie
are morbid screenwriters matt sesama and
burke sharpless who wrote the original
for jessica jones director sj clarkson
unfortunately an official release date
for sony's madame web has not been
announced yet
that's it for this week if you enjoyed
the video leave us a like and don't
forget to subscribe to not miss out on
any future news episodes you can also
check out the preview for the upcoming
dc blockbuster aquaman and the lost
kingdom on our channel or catch up on
the newly released jurassic world
dominion trailer in case you've missed
it
[Music]